first game in the champions chest or in
the skilling open it has actually
started david
that's right it has started and there we
see
a very mysterious
um
janna pomnishi on the left against
magnus carlsen who's deep in thought and
we have seen the spanish opening which
is i think both of them have been
playing their whole careers
um there will be a lot of moves a bit of
a flurry here at the beginning magnus
carlsen's actually chosen one of my own
favorite variations that i play a lot
especially on speed chess online yeah if
the bar points towards the left normally
that means that the player with the
white pieces is doing quite well it
means either they have a big advantage
in the position or they have maybe extra
material their points ahead they've got
extra pieces this is a very traditional
opening i think when the bar calms down
i think we will see that this is
supposed to be quite a good position for
white uh it has a very good reputation
for white magnus maybe provoking his
opponent station then um usually it
would be the side with more pawns in the
center of the board so here um white has
this pawn right in the center just a
couple of squares in front of his king
but the fighters i mean it's still early
days we have seen that black has traded
off a bishop for a night which is quite
a controversial trade um bishops and
knights they normally have roughly the
same value well we have some action
actually david because we have a queen
has come out to attack the pawn it's
sniffing sniffing around for danger
over here as well but that bishop is
defended by a white knight so
it's a very brave move bringing the
queen out too early and we have seen
that pawn has advanced so it is no
longer um threatened it is defended on
this square have decided what to do with
that king so we've seen a few more
trades david yes more trades more action
wow
and here we see white bringing the queen
out early in the game as well so um both
players
um i mean this is quite traditional
stuff i guess um i've had something very
similar to this before time to get some
space because space is amazing
oh what's happening yeah
magnus set a trap that's uh that's how
he likes to play chess nowadays he likes
to set these small tricks for his
opponent
um if we maybe just briefly jump in um
to the analysis board
we do see that a couple of moves very uh
naughty moves by magnus
i mean
in this position he's just jumped
forward with his knight to the center of
the board knights are very good in the
center of the ward they control uh lots
and lots of squares but he had a sneaky
threat to jump into this square
and that we would call that a fork
attacking the white king and attacking
the queen a double attack and black
would want a queen so white did stop
that i think he would be a bit baffled
be honest because this is a really great
british word
well i think so you know because he this
is the kind of position it's completely
unorthodox no one's seen this before
he's one of the quickest players on the
tour um he trusts his instincts more
than anyone i mean he knows i mean he's
been supremely talented from a young age
we mentioned
he believes in himself and i think he's
going to try and put magnus carson under
pressure on the clock early on and we
see under the names there white already
has a minute or so advantage yeah we see
magnus's face as well i don't think he's
too happy with this position
he's one of the few players without a
poker face on the chess tour and he
doesn't look too happy at all
um
maybe if we bring the board up as well
magnus has just castled with his king
which is a move that all of us try to do
um early in the game if we can black's
last move was to swap his king and rook
over the king goes two squares and the
rook jumps over it and this um and there
we see jana ponashi castle on the other
side of the board oh okay this is war
kaya wow this is war when that happens
that means that both sides are now going
to start advancing their pawns all the
way up the board and they want to attack
each other like crazy so it's it's gonna
it's red hot excitement here
when the night is on the edge it falls
off the head it's not very good october
night i'm gonna be fancy i'll show off
all the eight squares here always keep
your knight in the center of the board
at the moment it says 1.4 in white's
favor that just normally means he has a
nice position at the moment but that
could all change i mean one clumsy move
one uh one move uh one slip up could see
the bar swinging the whole other way and
we do have some quick moves here now
what's happening geary and now 11
aronian the best of luck and do tweet us
on the hashtag chesschamps tell us who
you're cheering for who do you think
you're gonna who's gonna win and uh who
does your heart cried out to win
and then we see a tweet from hikaru
nakamura himself back to work
he loves chess chess is not work for him
but uh it's great to see the players
tweeting as well yes
magnus has made a move and now young
napoleon just made a move what's
happening david that's right so um
magnus carlsen attacked white's bishop
that bishop has now retreated to come
and push those pawns on the queen side
forward
yeah i think
yes
they've read your mind
we've seen a couple more moves well a
big big attack and lots of nerves a bit
later on in the game so the queen side
will be the left-hand side of the board
so where the white king is sitting now
um if we imagine the board splits in
half uh the
four files the four lines on the
right-hand side of the board would be
the king side the right-hand side and
the queen side back to the board david
because magnus carlsen has given away
one of his horns and he's done this in
order to open up one line for that rook
when you're attacking opening up lines
it's currency you want to open as many
lines as possible against that white
king so the knight could get traded off
here but more importantly this line is
open for the black rook towards the
white king we could see a check oh
oh yeah the knights have been exchanged
actually here the knights have come off
the board and now magnus carson will be
thinking about whether to drop this
check on white it's almost checkmate
early on almost almost checkmate but the
king does have one safe square to run to
this is uh stressful stuff and it's
amazing jan the pondish is now three
minutes ahead of magnus on the clock
magnus there frowning trying to figure
out what to do how to get at that white
king it looks like his attack is quicker
but he has sacrificed a pawn so he is a
pawn down that's a big oh and we have
vienna pognanchi's picture as if by
magic wow
okay let's let's uh try to judge his
face expression here is he looking
satisfied happy what do you think ivanka
he's looking very calm actually a little
bit too
okay very hot here's another one without
a poker face
until he removed his hand away and then
i thought well maybe not he looks like
he's slightly concerned with the
position we have a very committal move
very surprising i did not expect that at
all from magnus carlsen he has just
moved his pawn that is on the right hand
side of the board forward i
would not have predicted that never in a
minute no that's right i wouldn't either
ifanka i mean
normally we're taught not to push horns
forward uh in front of our own king
magnus been thinking for almost two
minutes now on this move he's oh there
he made it and he keeps surprising
doesn't he
we haven't guessed any of his moves i
think today
there we see magnus has swung his rook
across a couple of squares eyeing up one
of white's pawns on that right-hand side
of the board that pawn is unprotected
right now it's not defended makes the
dream work those rooks need to be
connected
quote david
i'm all about the cheesy one-liners guys
um and yeah we have seen a move by jan
naponnishi he has pushed his pawn
forward so maybe if we just bring up the
board briefly um we show that that's a
very clever move actually yeah wow the
only one and they've worked together in
the past and um they've studied chess
together uh janna punishing he's helped
magnus prepare for tournaments so i
think that just shows magnus has a huge
amount of respect we see the bar
swinging slightly i think that's just
the computer kind of engaging trying to
understand the position we have some
extra moves so you see magnus for his
rook
move it up two squares and the king
finally moved into the hiding hole
i think that's a big indicator that
things might have gone a bit wrong for
magnus
um and then
moving them so quickly yeah exactly and
magnus has brought his rook back to a
square it was on just a few moves ago so
magnus maybe a bit indecisive here oh
what happened to the bar oh the bar it's
it's edging towards that left side ever
further um i think white's position is
fantastic here wow wow quick games i
mean these early rounds i think players
will just be sussing each other out they
don't want to take too many risks um
they can't qualify for those knockout
stages this early on but if they lose a
few games they could
yeah they could definitely be out of um
we do actually see in the game black has
uh checked the opponent's king
if we bring up the board we can show
that
black here he's brought his queen
forward his last move
is a check along the diagonal that's a
bit of a scary one to face and here
white will be thinking
one move he doesn't want to play is he
doesn't want to play his king back
because this would allow a checkmate in
one move oh he did move his pawn
therefore block
there was a lot of danger with that
check david a lot of danger but yeah
he yeah he's good enough he doesn't
he won't fall into those checkmates yeah
lots more for magnus to think about he's
retreating with his rook
feels like maybe he's a bit nervous
maybe he's not in the zone right now
he's brought his rook forward then he's
had to retreat it a couple of minutes
later a little bit there's too much
dancing going going on and not enough
planning that's how you want your works
ready for action
and magnus once again it seems
retreating his queen or does he have a
plan with this to to bring her out on
another side yeah i think ivanka was
about to mention quite a cool motif that
might appear on the board um we could
see something called alakine's gun yeah
um which would be if all the major
pieces stacked up um on the same files
will be ganging up against white's pawn
here in the center so
um
oh and there we see oh that was
unexpected because instead of defending
this pawn
on the in the center magnus has gone for
a counter attack he wants that pawn on
the right hand side of the board that's
close to that king yeah that's right
loose pawns drop off and oh i didn't
expect that oh and magnus is just magnus
just giving it away wow uh magnus has
allowed so his last move um has been to
push push the pawn forward he is
attacking the rook so the rook will run
away um but now white has a huge choice
have we seen a blunder oh because the
bar is actually saying that this is
gone
is magnus now suddenly winning this yes
i think his last move might have been a
genius stroke um
oh i think so
there's there's a nasty little idea here
black wants to bring he's just cleared
the lawyer for his queen to jump over to
the queen side and maybe come and check
this king
um wow i did not see that one coming it
looks like black's just setting up this
threat against the rook but for example
if white were to take this pawn looks
like a free pawn black would swing his
queen across and maybe this is going to
be checkmate that's queen could come and
check the king
on two squares and
wow i mean i'd love to see the player
cameras maybe right now to see whether
yeah
he might be shaking his head um
turn around in two moves i mean this is
crazy this is the beauty of chess
everything can change maybe if we i'd
love to see whether napoli's shaking his
head here no his
helix he looks quite calm but i would be
panicking i would be panicking now we
see magnus is pushing oh did you see
that look on his face
like rub your eyes oh no
he was in control for so long
just to clear phone up and he didn't
take care of the king kaya um
yeah i mean okay but we see the bar now
swinging back and forth the computer's
simply having a very hard time peter's
uh confused just as much as punishing as
well uh i think um the game isn't over
yet so um if we bring up the board to
show magnus his idea um
is to play maybe a queen check in this
position there's a huge check on uh this
square right next to the white king
right now um this would be attacking
white's king white's king is um well in
mortal danger now i think yeah um for
sure we will see this check
the enemy queen next to the king
and it has appeared on the board we have
seen a chat queen checks the king the
king has to run there's no choice about
it he just has to skedaddle out of there
and he did that right away yeah he did
that right away but black is spoiled for
choice now black could give another
check with his queen attacking the white
king um black could also capture uh in
the center of the board to try and
distract the white forces i mean magnus
is frowning slightly
maybe uh yes so he has given a check and
he's won back that pawn yes and still
that white king is in mortal danger look
at it out there in the open with
it's got a lot of pieces next to it can
he
true white does have a lot of defending
pieces but when the queens are still on
the board um i think a king out in the
open should not survive too long
what's happening oh no
surely not is that no no i just oh my
god
we've seen a mouse slip kaya no magnus
carlson is it true yes he's dropped his
queen on the wrong square and we see the
results just popped up oh we need to see
the picture of magnus now look at his
face magnus realizes he's had a mouse
lip he simply put the piece on a
different square than what he meant to
and you see also janna pognaat she
actually seems like he's feeling sorry
for magnus
this is one of those things
that is in the lap of the internet gods
it's just one of those things that
happens you pick up you pick up the
queen in magnus's case and you put it in
the wrong square and it's devastating
but you just have to accept this much
when some you lose some this must feel
devastating to magnus carlsen he was
actually winning this game in fantastic
fashion and now
um where it could be taken by the white
pawn or the white rook and
um yeah i think janna ponnachi i mean of
course he'll take the win but he doesn't
want to win like that
and magnus it's extra harsh because he
has a winning position i think
and judging by
the pictures that we see of these
players now how are they feeling
i mean well you can just see it you can
just see it in magnus's face he is angry
and this is one of the things with
online chess all the emotions are
intensified when you make a mistake such
as this because it really isn't quite
your fault you would never make this
kind of mistake over the board but it's
something that happens in online chess
and it makes you angry at the same time
when you win a game you can see
you can actually see the hidden elation
in hindi
he escaped with it he got away with it